Anthony let's say it's 2012 again and
you have a family member or a friend who
wrote you a check for 50 grand and said
go to LA and spend this money on
something that's going to propel your
career and the checks good okay okay
that's the important part what are you
spending that money on and in what
series of payments and what are you
doing with that sure sure first I'm
gonna say thank you okay right shake the
ham look the person in the eye say thank
you that's uh you know what in all
honesty I wouldn't I kind of came out
here like that business side of it I
wouldn't have spent anything crazy I
would have possibly gotten better
headshots paid somebody to do the real
instead of me doing it myself small
things like that but I think having that
in the bank and having that little extra
kind of cushion of money is like we
talked about going back to the money
situation or as like when it comes it's
fantastic and the ability to have that
freedom to pursue other avenues with the
financial backing is is a good thing and
take the only thing I've said I would
have done sorry to go back is I probably
would have put the money in and bought
my own nicer camera to do like an home
auditions but nothing over the top I
just have like a little mini cam but
nowadays people doing them people are
doing them on iPhone so okay so so it
sounds like you would do pretty much
everything you're doing now just
everything might be a little nicer right
what if a little bit more money behind
certain things but yeah I don't need any
things around it's not like I would've
got a car crazy brand-new car I moved
into a bigger place just because I could
and like I said it goes back to kind of
that six-month plan where it was like
this is what I'm doing this is how much
money I put aside maybe the six month
would have gone into a year but have
been this is what I'm doing this how
much money I have this is what I want to
accomplish and if I don't that's either
I'm not working hard I'm not doing it
right or I need to reevaluate and that
50,000 would have just kind of I think
given a little take a little bit of
weight off my shoulders in a way so I
could add extra guacamole whenever I
wanted to wherever I was without having
to think twice that would have been a
big thing really table side table oh you
kidding me I would have just had all the
time I didn't have avocados for the
first year I think that would have been
a big
in my my demeanor but no I really you
know it's not like I grew up in a you
know in a dirt field but it's not like I
grew up in a twenty bedroom mansion
either so kind of just having that
blue-collar mentality and put away and
use it for what you need it for but I
think I went about things right which
you know people helping me out people
giving me a good advice do you think if
let this hypothetical 50 grand aside
from a little bit of a better camera or
a little bit better headshots you would
have maybe done a production where you
could have paid done a feature earlier I
would have the first thing I did out
here was a short-form web series that
got picked up with Funny or Die that
future data was called knocking on doors
and I would put up a lot more money
behind that and I had written out ten
episodes we only got to shoot three
because everyone in it is just doing
that at the goodness of their heart
people that are just starting out actors
that are friends that I've met that
weren't busy on a Sunday afternoon and
wanted to be in something that I thought
was funny so if I could do that portion
again Oh 100% would have put more money
behind some of these individual projects
because if it's my own thing it's not a
big deal really
to me personally if I get paid for it if
I'm doing it I'm doing everything behind
it I mean granted yes I would love to
get paid but for these smaller ones to
be able to pay your crew and your cast
people that are taking time away from
whatever else they have going on in
their life family friends there are
other jobs to help you out
to be able to pay them would have been
make happier workers really but it
sounds like peace of mind then really
helps you know yeah being out here so
you know yeah I think the financial
aspect for all up-and-coming people in
the artistic industry however you want
to put that always have that small
burden of you know I should have stayed
at corporate Joe industries great
company or whatever have you so let's
say money stress versus maybe not total
financial freedom where you're you know
on an island phoning in what you've done
but a little more comfortable
well how does that look in the big
scheme of things and how you approach
life uh you know what there was when I
first got in comedy like in Chicago one
of my improv teachers had an awesome
quote that Amy Poehler once said and I'm
gonna butcher it it's probably to be
completely wrong and someone probably
may be actually in the making it up on
Wikipedia but it was Amy Poehler said
that if you want to get into the comedy
world or the acting and entertainment
industry in general get ready to be
broke for ten years and then hope one of
your friends makes it big and that was
just you know and she's half serious and
she's half not and she's a you know
she's fantastic
I'm negative thing anyone could ever say
about it so it's just really cool to
hear someone that's succeeding yeah
someone that's succeeded succeeded
apparently she's uh seated from the I'm
gonna take that back there's someone
that has so much success in this
industry to realize oh she went through
all this as well and and she understands
it that was kind of cool and I think
kind of that approach going back to kind
of take that to life it's like if you're
doing what you're doing that what you'd
love to do like you're gonna have these
hurdles to overcome whatever it is music
same thing no band just plays in the
garage one time and then it's headlining
the next day it just doesn't happen like
that there has to be some passion behind
it
you